all anyone wants to talk about is the
kyle rittenhouse trial and the lynch mob
forming around the written house trial
and the fate of kenosha wisconsin when
the verdict finally comes down and we
will get to all of that because there
are lots of new developments that make
an already inept and corrupt prosecution
look even worse
but before we do we've got to take a
break to toast some rare
good news
osha the government agency that joe
biden is wielding to make everyone take
the fouchy algae
osha has just announced that it will
stop enforcing joe biden's illegal
vaccine mandate as a result of lawsuits
most notably
the lawsuit brought by yours truly here
at the daily wire which we were able to
bring thanks to the support of you of
every single one of you who have come
out and helped us and signed the
petition and listened and subscribed so
for those who have not been following
the developments
joe biden issued the mandate
then we sued him
then a federal court told the government
to stop enforcing the mandate then joe
biden told the government to ignore the
court then this is the crucial part we
kept suing them
and then the government agency folded
like a cheap suit at least for now i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
my favorite comment yesterday from old
schooled who said the one upside of the
supply chain issue is that shelves are
sitting mostly empty for when the
verdict is red that's true that will
reduce the
early black friday
shopping that goes on the cashless
payment-free shopping that is almost
certain to go on in kenosha from the
mostly peaceful looters
when you are holiday shopping
when you are just shopping for yourself
something you really want to focus on is
getting a good night sleep and if you
want a wonderful magnificent night's
sleep you got to check out helix it's
been a long day it's been a long
month it's been a long year or a year
and a half and when you're just so
exhausted i'm telling you one of the
great constellations in the world
is just flopping onto your helix
mattress when you get home helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete matches your body type and
sleep references to the perfect mattress
for you why would you buy a mattress
made for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep they've
got soft medium and firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress you're matched to
mattress comes right to your door ship
for free they got a 10 year warranty you
get to try it yourself for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you are
going to love it they've got great
financing options flexible payment plans
so a great night of sleep is never far
away helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com knowles
that's 200 bucks off and two free
pillows at helixsleep.com
knowles
big win for us
on this osha
ruling osha now holding off on the
fauciachi you do not
take the fouchyauchi if you don't want
to do not feel pressured to take the
fauchiachi until this litigation is
resolved even the government agency
backed
down you've got to push back on these
people folks because we have a corrupt
government and you're seeing that play
out very clearly
in kenosha
so
if you've been following the trial and i
know you have because we have been
covering it pretty closely on this show
you'll know that the prosecution has
flopped every single step of the way
everything that we were told by the
media about kyle rittenhouse about
kenosha about the shooting
basically everything we were told was bs
all of the arguments that the
prosecution made fell flat all of the
evidence was on kyle rittenhouse's side
and the side of his self-defense claims
and none of the evidence was on the
prosecution side
a lot of it came down to footage from
the night there were a lot of cameras
out there and apparently law enforcement
had
a drone going over and was able to view
what was going on and who shot when and
who turned when and who turned where so
take a look
at the footage that the defense had the
kyle rittenhouse team had compared to
the footage that the prosecution
had
you can if you're if you're just
listening right now i will describe to
you the difference it's pretty pretty
clear
the defense had very very blurry grainy
footage it looks like it was taken on a
flip phone from i don't know 2002
the prosecution had crystal clear
high definition incredible footage where
you could make out every little detail
it's not even close and you can just
look at the size of the files the
defense had video that was 3.6 megabytes
the
prosecution had video that was 11.2
megabytes
so
you're talking about three times the
quality for the prosecution as for
the defense so
so what happened
well when this was was brought up the
the prosecution made the argument said
no look all we did we just copied the
file we gave look we gave the defense
the same file and look if there was a
problem with the quality of the footage
you know the crucial evidence in this
case it's just because the defense teams
you know their cell phones were wrong or
their or their computers were messed up
but it's not because we didn't do
anything we're not hiding evidence
it's something on your end you had the
exact same file now here's how the
defense proved that was complete
bs
every other piece of evidence from the
state prime lab in this situation has
been provided to us via dropbox dropbox
provides an exact forensic copy of what
they have the file title name in this
situation should have been exactly the
same as the one provided to the state if
it was the exact same copy
the file name was nowhere near similar
there's no way that what ada kraus is
saying is true because
the file name would not have changed if
my computer was compressing anything it
was a different file that we were
provided from what was provided to the
state
she's got these guys dead to rights
i never want to attribute to malice that
which is equally explained by stupidity
and the prosecution has demonstrated a
lot of stupidity in this case the
arguments they're making where they say
that if you if you arm yourself you lose
the right to self-defense of course
that's
preposterous
if arming yourself would would lose you
your right to self-defense then there
simply is no right to self-defense the
the prosecution lifting up an ar-15 in a
courtroom swinging it around the
courtroom finger on the trigger i mean
just pure stupidity so i'm not i'm not
denying that they could have been stupid
enough
not to realize what they did but this
required an intentional action
you would have had to go in there
you would have had to reduce the quality
of the video
and you would have had to change the
file name
so this can't be just a problem of copy
paste whoops it
it read differently on a different
computer
the prosecution provided the defense
with a different file a file that was
much lower quality a file that put them
at a much
at a real disadvantage
for the crucial evidence in
the case and these guys are corrupt okay
it's as simple as that
they are corrupt they might also be
stupid they might also be ignorant they
might also be incompetent
but i'm seeing malice
i am seeing corruption here and i think
we all are well why did they do it
why did they do whatever happened and
now this is what's delaying the verdict
is now going to hear testimony about the
file however this happened
why would the prosecution have done it
because all of their arguments were weak
we didn't get to this clip the other day
i want to play it just to remind you of
the the
weakness of the prosecution's argument
one of their closing arguments was that
kyle rittenhouse had no right to shoot
back at the people who were trying to
kill him some of whom had guns because
everybody takes a beating sometimes
these minor injuries we've heard the
defendant have
again
mr richards misstated
the standard
it is not could have caused great bodily
harm or death
it is not likely to have caused great
bodily harm or death
it is imminent threat
of death or great bodily harm
where is that when you get a couple
scrapes
everybody takes the beating sometimes
right
sometimes you get in uh a scuffle and
maybe you do get hurt a little bit
that doesn't mean you get to start
plugging people with your full metal
jacket ar-15 rounds and no bullets or
not bullets
and no bullets are not bullets i think
he's trying to make an argument that the
ar-15 is a more powerful weapon than the
handgun that the people trying to kill
kyle rittenhouse had but first of all i
don't think that's a great defense
either you're if someone's coming at you
with a gun threatening to kill you and
telling you explicitly they're going to
kill you you can only shoot back with a
gun of of equal or lesser lethality is
that i don't remember that provision of
the law
i don't remember the everybody takes a
beating sometimes provision of the law
do you
did you see that anywhere in the second
amendment
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed so long as
they take a beating sometimes
but after one or two beatings then
you're allowed to fight back but only
with a nine mil you're not allowed to
fight back with two two three
you're not that you that would be
i don't think so i think that's pretty
pretty weak uh yes it's true people
people take a beating every now and
again you know if you if you went to
public school presumably at some point
someone punched you right at some point
you got into a fight at some that that's
true
it is not incumbent upon you if you are
in a riot situation with people
explicitly threatening to kill you who
are walking up to you with skateboards
and with guns
it is not
your responsibility to take the beating
what kyle written has only got a couple
scrapes on him he wasn't at imminent
risk of grave bodily injury or death no
he was he only got a couple scrapes on
him because he defended himself
successfully
you don't you don't need to wait until
they break your arm to
or shoot you in the head to shoot back
you have the right to defend yourself
and i suspect even this
incompetent prosecution i suspect they
know that and i suspect they know that
their case was nothing and that this
never should have been brought to trial
in the first place and so they tried to
cheat
you can see this picture
that uh the that we're painting for you
here this picture of what's actually
going on in the courthouse if you want a
beautiful picture not an ugly picture
but a beautiful picture i would
recommend you check out paint your life
probably the single most special gift
that you can give to a loved one this
christmas season or even your number one
loved one you in many cases would be
paint your life i love it i have paint
your life work hanging on my walls i've
given it to friends and family
you the way it works is you take a photo
or maybe more than one photo of a loved
one of a special place of a pet you send
it in their world-class artists will
paint a hand-painted painting from that
photo or those photos
it is really really high quality i was
skeptical of it so the first one i did i
made it it was going to be a gift for my
stepbrother and then i saw the final
product i said oh my gosh this is
world-class art the price is really
really really reasonable and it really
helps beautify your home at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your
money's refunded guaranteed right now is
a limited offer get 20 off your painting
hurry up and go get it right now 20 off
plus free shipping to get this special
offer text the word michael to 64 000.
that's m-i-c-h-a-e-l to 64 000 text
michael to 64 thousand paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
term supply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms that is michael
texted to 64 000.
because of the
corruption because of the shenanigans
because of the dirty tricks
that the prosecution played where they
gave the defense
lower quality evidence than they had
the defense has filed a motion for a
mistrial
a mistrial with prejudice
what is a mistrial with prejudice
does not mean that the mistrial is a
white supremacist does not mean
that what it means is
the case is dismissed and the state
can't bring it again
so if if this were granted kyle gets off
the hook
and he can't be brought up again we're
not going to have another written house
trial next year
unless there's rioting and unless kyle
goes and tries to protect his uh
community and property and then you know
unless someone tries to kill him again
and then he shoots them back then i
guess we'll be stuck in that cycle and
we'll go we'll go right back but
but as of right now the defense is
trying to get this this mistrial with
prejudice
the video footage has been at the center
of this case says the defense
the failure to provide the same quality
footage in this particular case is
intentional and clearly prejudice is the
defendant so i agree with that i think
that's probably true but my first
reaction when i heard that they were
going for a mistrial was why
all of the evidence is on your side none
of the evidence is on the state side
it's clear as day people
people have been following this case
from the beginning the prosecution's got
nothing why would you go for a mistrial
when you can win outright
if i were on this jury and i've
been paying pretty close attention to
this trial it wouldn't it's not even
close
so why not try to win outright well
the answer is
that there are other factors at play
here beyond the evidence
the jury is afraid for their lives
as they rightly should be so they're
getting a ton of political pressure
including from the president of the
united states joe biden doing doing the
same thing that biden did
in other trials
george floyd for instance
but
beyond that if you're a juror on this if
you're a juror in this trial
you know that if you don't throw this
kid to the wolves and lock them up and
throw away the key
then
you are going to be harassed you're
going to be doxxed there are going to be
riots they're going to burn your
community down the left has already said
they're doing that
they're marching outside the courthouse
right now
saying
shut it down
if kenosha don't get it shut it down
what does shut it down mean it means do
the same thing that they did the last
time that caused the trial in the first
place namely burn down the city attack
people steal things
and and you can get any information you
want these days so
you really think the identity of these
jurors is going to be protected no way
and you really think the the violent
leftist mob the lynch mob that's outside
going for kyle rittenhouse you think
they're not going to attack these jurors
no they will and so i get it the right
thing to do in this case would be to
acquit kyle of all the charges
but
i like to think if i were on the jury
that i would do that
but what if you were on the jury
what if you have young kids you have a
wife that you love what if you've got a
nice house
do you really want to ruin your life
do you really want to put all of that at
risk
because our
systems right now are are not sturdy
because the left is undermining our
entire system of justice
no
i think the defense believes that the
although all the evidence is on their
side if if everything were functioning
as it should kyle would be acquitted but
i think they're afraid the jury is going
to go wobbly because of the threats
and so they're going to try to go for a
mistrial fair enough speaking of threats
nancy pelosi just censured a republican
representative
paul gosar so his party line vote and
and they're censuring paul gosar because
he sent out some spicy tweets or
something you know
he did the sort of thing that dems do
all the time but he did it he's a
republican so they're going to censure
him
lauren beaubert another
firebrand conservative member of
congress came out in defense of
congressman gosar democrat policies are
so pathetic and have done so poorly that
the left has nothing else to do patrol
the internet looking for ways to get
offended and then try to target members
and strip them of their committees this
is a dumb waste of the house's time but
since the speaker has designated the
floor to discuss members inappropriate
actions
shall we
the jihad squad member from minnesota
has paid her husband and not her brother
husband the other one over a million
dollars in campaign funds this member is
allowed on the foreign affairs committee
while praising terrorists
a democrat chairwoman incited further
violence in the streets outside of a
courthouse and then the cherry on top
my colleague and three-month
presidential candidate from california
who is on the intelligence committee
slept with fang fang a chinese spy
let me say that again a member of
congress who receives classifieds
sleeping with the enemy this is
unacceptable
i love it i love it
jihad squad member ilhan omar was
illegally or certainly crookedly paying
off her husband not her brother husband
by the way the other husband oh my gosh
stop it stop it they're already dead
stop it don't keep kicking them while
they're down
uh eric swalwell was sleeping with fang
fang a chinese spy
she's never denied
oh gosh
i love it there are going to be very
sophisticated republicans
who are at very prestigious think tanks
and
stodgy dusty institutions they're going
to say this is not right this is not no
don't do this we're better than that
don't no don't make all these jokes
about all these degenerate democrat
members of congress it's so no i think
it's it's funny it's funny it's just
it's jokes and the jokes have a basis in
reality because ilhan omar really does
have a kind of strange personal history
and she actually has praised terrorists
and laughed and said 911 is some people
did something hahaha and
she says oh call you done she kind of
giggles and laughs on camera we have all
of this eric swallow really did sleep
with a chinese spy that actually did
happen
so basis in reality it's funny
the
attacks on republican members of
congress like paul goes are completely
disingenuous it's a complete double
standard and we should mock them
relentlessly i just there's a little
rhetorical
lesson in this that lauren bobert is
teaching us
if she had been timid and said you know
ilhan omar i'm not sure she's very loyal
to this country i'm not i just think she
the way she's talked about some foreign
terror groups it's not if if you if you
went
into that kind of an attack with that
timidity
of a kind of
old dusty republican
you would get an avalanche of
accusations of racism and xenophobia and
islamophobia and phobia phobia and you
would be and then you'd be buried in
that but if you come out and say yeah
she's a member of the jihad squad and
she loves al qaeda
there's nothing you can't there's
nothing to come back at that with you're
so
confident you're so oh it's
it's like when you're trying to talk to
a girl when you're a teenager you're
trying to pick up a girl in high school
or something
you can if you go really timid and she
was like hey um hi there shelley um
would you like to maybe go to the prom
with me sometime i kind of like you for
a bit then you're gonna seem weak and
you're gonna get pulled over but if you
go and you say hey cutie you're you're
great i really like you a lot let's go
you and me let's go to the prom together
you're just going to seem more confident
and the lesson that's true of your
interpersonal life your lesson that's
true of just
personal social relations that's also
true in politics
and the other lesson from this is
we've got to do to the democrats what
they are doing to us nothing
i'm not saying we do something that is
immoral or unjust but as a matter of
procedural politics let's do the same
thing nancy pelosi is going to use a
party-line vote to strip republicans of
their committees okay well let's just do
that to them next time the minute that
republicans have the house which could
be
sooner than the democrats expect let's
strip ilhan omar of her committees let's
strip
rashida talib and aoc and
all the rest of these radical let's
strip eric swalwell for sure of his
committees
let's do it why not they're doing it to
us
and the the left responds
to force they respond to confidence they
respond to strength
okay and so let's use our political
force
let's strip them of their committees
let's mock them on the floor of the
house
well done
lauren bobert
there are a lot of problems going on
caused by
bad politicians in this country notably
our gas prices going up which is why i
would recommend you check out get upside
gas is very expensive
thanks to our friends in washington dc
among other people
and so i'm going to save you money at
the gas pump every time you go you can
thank me later it's all really thanks to
get upside our listeners are making up
to 25 cents for every single gallon of
gas every single time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles canon wles get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up up to 50 cents cash back do not
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside down load the
app for free use promo code knowles k w
l e s to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank
people who are driving a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back there's no cash
there's only cash goes straight to your
bank account or if you prefer paypal or
an e-gift card for amazon or other
brands super easy right now save up to
50 cents per gallon on your first tank
that is code knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
at the free get upside app
in some of the biggest news i mentioned
this a little bit at the top of the show
that we have received since filing our
lawsuit the biden administration has
announced that it's suspending the the
mandate it has to even ocean not just
joe biden but osha itself the fight is
just getting started right now so
we've still got a long way to go before
we win sign our petition against joe
biden's vaccine mandate over at
dailywire.com do not comply we've had
over 600 000 people sign the petition
the more signatures we get the louder at
the message that is why we're aiming to
get to one million signatures head on
over to dailywire.com do not comply to
sign the petition today we'll be right
back with a lot more
we've got some great news from the
cancel culture
usually cancel culture only brings us
bad news where people who contradict
leftist orthodoxy have their lives
ruined because of some tweet they sent
10 years ago or some email they sent 15
years ago but here today we've got some
good good news from the cancel culture
that pedophile defending professor that
we
we played on the show a couple of days
ago alan walker is a professor at old
dominion university he was the one who's
trying to destigmatize pedophilia change
the term pedophile to minor attracted
persons
and and normalize sexual attraction to
kids
he has been placed on leave
so
he has
written about this in a book he's given
presentations about why we
basically need to be nicer to pedophiles
and destigmatize them and he has been
placed on leave now i know
some right wingers some conservatives
say the cancel culture is always bad and
we don't want to cancel and the left
cancels and we don't cancel that is not
my position i wrote an entire book about
how that's not my position my position
is the cancel culture can be a very good
thing it's not about do you cancel or do
you not cancel it's about what do you
cancel all cultures are going to cancel
some things
pedophiles for instance i think it's
good to cancel pedophiles
i think it's bad to cancel
christians
okay i think those are those are
different things and so it's not just
the form that matters it's the substance
what are you actually advocating why are
you being canceled and so i am thrilled
that this guy is getting canceled
now here's his defense which was sent
out in a statement from the university
quote
i want to be clear child sexual abuse is
morally wrong and an inexcusable crime
as an assistant professor of sociology
and criminal justice the goal of my
research is to prevent crime my work is
informed by my past experience and
advocacy as a social worker counseling
victims i embarked on this research in
hopes of gaining understanding of a
group that previously had not been
studied in order to identify ways to
protect children so first of all
pedophiles have been studied before
that's not you're not you're not quite
so groundbreaking as you think you are
mr walker but
but also you didn't embark on the
research just to gain understanding to
say punish these people more you said
you wanted to destigmatize pedophiles
that's why you wanted to change the term
from pedophile which has a bad
connotation you know it's a neutral term
in and of itself it just refers to
having a liking for an attraction for
two children
but it's got a stigma because the thing
itself is evil and so you you know
obviously the word gains this
the ugliness of the reality of it and
you said you want to take that away and
call them minor attracted persons and
maps
and that would be wrong
so this guy
walker is obviously very confused
i think he calls himself non-binary so
he doesn't know his own sex and he's
he's a very confused person obviously
but his argument is i'm not
advocating that we abuse children i'm
saying that we destigmatize the idea of
having a sexual desire for children but
that's wrong too
okay it's it's important to recognize
yes obviously it's wrong to abuse the
children
it is also wrong to have sexual desire
for children the desire itself
is also wrong and it's very difficult
for people in our modern hippy-dippy
society to understand that
because what we are told today is that
desire is never wrong it's just your
actions that are wrong
so if you're a pedophile a minor
attracted person to use this guy's crazy
language then it's wrong if you abuse
kids but it's not wrong if you think
about
sleeping with a child it's not because
that's just your desire it's just in
your head and you have total autonomy
over your mind and your and your body
and you can do whatever you want as long
as it doesn't hurt anybody else and and
you have self-ownership and no no
desires can be wrong right
especially especially if you're born
this way right if the pedophile is born
this way let's say that that's the case
let's just go with that premise
then certainly the desire can't be wrong
that's a very liberal
idea
and some people on the right believe
that kind of thing too the kind of pro
drug pro
sleep around pro do whatever you want
right they believe that too as long as
it's consensual it's totally fine
the problem with with pedophilia is it's
not consensual but the desire is also
wrong
too the conservative view of this
is that the desire is wrong as well and
it must be stigmatized it is rightly
stigmatized and moreover
that
we can shape our desires
all right this is this is a real
sticking point for some people
but you actually can shape your desires
i'm not saying you have total control
over your desires
but you can shape them addicts know this
when an addict starts out he doesn't
have a penchant for heroin
right he doesn't but he takes the first
drug whatever he's probably it's some
kind of gateway drug and then he gets
into the heroin and then all of a sudden
his desires turn toward the heroine
and at a certain point depending on how
bad the addiction gets especially with a
hard drug like heroin
all of his desires are oriented toward
the heroin
then if he goes through a process of
rehabilitation and recovery
what is that doing what that does is
turns your desire away from the heroine
a lot of rock stars will say this
they'll say you know back in the 80s i
was totally addicted to heroin now i'm
totally addicted to working out or
something right now i'm addicted to
exercise you kind of turn that and
ultimately the place you want to turn
your desires is toward god
not just your actions not just your
behaviors but even your very
desire what is it that you're thinking
about when you put your head on your
pillow at night
all right and that it's not a very
liberal idea it's not it doesn't mean
you have total emancipation and total
liberation total control over your body
and whatever you want to do is okay
it's saying no it's not
even that desire that you can't totally
control that is wrong so not only can
you not act on it but you've got to work
to try to transform that desire in any
way you can
and you're going to you're probably
going to fail a lot and you know maybe
you're never going to totally do that
but you you've got to work on that
as well
speaking of morality nancy pelosi
has moral lessons for all of us isn't
that rich nancy pelosi is insisting that
if we don't back her global warming
agenda
that we are violating the moral
imperative
to take care of the earth
over
about half a trillion dollars in this
legislation
to protect the planet it's a health
issue clean air clean water for our
children it's a jobs issue making
america preeminent and good paying green
jobs you know all of the challenge of
natural disasters springing from the
climate crisis and it is a moral issue
if you believe as i do that this is
god's creation and we have a moral
obligation to be good stewards but even
if you don't share that view
religiously we all share it morally that
we have a responsibility to future
generations
nancy pelosi is a little confused she
says even if you don't believe it
religiously we all believe it morally
but of course our moral views are
synonymous with our religious views so
she's making a distinction that doesn't
really exist and she says look we've got
an obligation moral religious
profound obligation to be stewards of
god's creation
i agree with that
people
are maybe disagreeing with nancy pelosi
or i'm not disagreeing with her in
principle i totally agree with that
she's absolutely right
the problem is that nancy pelosi does
not agree with that she doesn't really
believe that
if she really believed that she would
oppose
abortion
we are stewards of god's creation yeah
we are
and we need to be very nice to the the
rabbits
and the sheep and even the trees
and the fish
and so on the polar bears
and we need to be good and just the
the clouds
and the ozone and we've got to be good
stewards of what we've got to care and
not harm any of these things
but we can vacuum up a human baby and
that's a wonderful thing that's
something to celebrate
we can't disturb the patterns of the
clouds and the way that the gentle
fragile ecosystem and the delta smelt we
can't touch the delta smelt
but we can chop up a little baby to the
tune of a million of them a year is that
really is that true
is that how that works i don't think
that's true because
there is an order to creation
and there are some things are higher in
creation than others and and nancy
pelosi is admitting that herself if it's
true that we have a special
responsibility to be stewards of
creation it's because we have dominion
over the whole rest of the the creation
over the earth and the birds of the
trees and the fowl and the fish of the
sea
because we are higher than them and so
it is very disordered to say we need to
take care of the delta smelt
but we have the right to
chop up little innocent human babies
that doesn't make
any sense at all
some conservatives go way too far in in
their reaction against this kind of
thing
and i understand it's because it's so
disingenuous but they'll say we have no
obligations to to take care of the
environment we have no let's just knock
it all down and put up a bunch of
factories and make a bunch of widgets no
i don't think that's true either we do
we do have an obligation to do that
but
nancy pelosi's understanding of that
moral obligation is completely flipped
on its head the delta smelt are
everything in human babies according to
her are nothing
really for them
for the left climate change
global warming global cooling whatever
is just an excuse
to take more political power chuck
schumer admitted this just a couple days
ago
last year with covid was awful
but in a few years because of climate
change each year will be worse than
covid and each year will be worse than
the next if we don't do anything about
it
well this year it's been tough you know
and uh but
we just you thought you were coming out
of that now you thought that we were
finally going to restore normal order to
society no no
it's only going to get worse and it's
not going to get worse because of some
virus that we can kind of measure it's
going to be because of the sun monster
and it's not going to be anything that's
happening right now but it's because of
things that could happen in 10 years
unless you do exactly what we say and
give us all your money and give us all
your rights and just let us upend the
political order
he he's sort of right
he's sort of right if his argument is
you thought kovald was bad just wait
until global warming he's sort of right
though not in the way that he thinks he
is
because the biggest issue with kovid was
not the virus it was
the lockdown
right viruses exist
diseases germs exist there's nothing
really new about that and if kovid was a
little more virulent than some other
viruses and diseases though a lot less
virulent than many others as well
then okay that's a natural fact of life
what was different about kovid
is that we shut down all of society over
it and lost all of our political rights
and power and closed churches and
allowed these psychos in washington to
to become much more powerful than they
already were
and disrupt the supply chains and kick
people out of work and and we're still
giving them a lot of power that's what
our lawsuit against the biden
administration right now is really
fighting against
it was it was the lockdowns and so what
the left is trying to do now
is go from
the covid justification
to the global warming justification and
keep the same kind of lockdown policies
they're they're totally changing the
rationale
for their political power grab but
they're trying to keep the exact same
power grab
maybe
maybe we ought to have learned a lesson
from covid not the lesson chuck schumer
thinks we learned he thinks the lesson
we learned is we better
we better give them all the power
we better not mess around with them we
better give them whatever they want i
think the lesson is no don't give them
an inch don't give them
an inch because there are much bigger
public health threats than the wuhan
virus there are much bigger public
health threats than the sun monster
here's one
for the first time ever last year
the associated press is reporting from
public health officials in the u.s that
a hundred thousand americans died of
drug overdoses
in one year
just one year
the number jumped 30 percent in one year
why is that
what changed
was it just because was it the weather
that changed
was it random or was it maybe because we
threw a lot of people out of work we
kicked people out of their churches we
wouldn't let people see their friends
and family members we locked them all up
with nothing to do idle hands are the
devil's playground
we
have given these pharmaceutical
companies and drug cartels on the
southern border carte blanche to do
whatever they want
and now a lot of people died
why maybe it has something to do with
that maybe
you know we talk about how some of the
coveted numbers are inflated because for
parts of the lockdowns if you got shot
in the head but you tested positive for
cova that was a covid death so the
official statistics are
difficult to believe
a lot of a lot of us think the official
the real number is significantly lower
but then maybe we need to add a hundred
thousand here or at least some portion
of that
here
because those deaths seems to me would
be exacerbated
would be encouraged by the lockdown
politic policies that the public health
geniuses tell us we're going to save all
of our lives
this was the big problem with allowing
dr fauci and dr scarf to run all those
white house press conferences you
remember in the early days of covid back
in those halcyon trump years trump would
hold the press conferences and he would
be flanked by all the public health
officials and they would you know
thought she would get up and say you see
go don't wear the mask oh actually do
wear the mask oh whatever i say is
gospel truth and he'd go up and then dr
scarf would say whatever she was going
to say and then that jerk surgeon
general would get up and say what he was
going to say it was all the public
health people and the mistake there was
not even necessarily that he held the
press conferences not even necessarily
that those knuckleheads talked
it was that they were the only people
speaking
but
the country is not just run by egghead
epidemiologists and it should not be at
least
trump also probably should have had an
economist get up there and speak trump
also probably should have had a national
security figure get up there and speak
trump also should have probably had a
constitutional expert get up there and
speak trump also could have had an
historian get up there and speak to talk
about the norms in this country
any other number of people because
politics is
is an art of balancing competing
interests
and yes it's true that if you you know
if if dr fauci were given
all of the political power in the
country i guess he sort of has been
then he would view every public matter
through the lens of epidemiology
even to the destruction of
businesses to destruction of
civil liberties to the destruction of
churches to the destruction of
interpersonal relationships
and traditions
and ironically even the public health
because if you're only focused on
eradicating one virus maybe you're
ignoring the deaths of despair that are
going on suicides and drug overdoses too
you need to balance these things
you can't just give some egghead expert
specialist control over your whole
country speaking of following the
science jedediah mila from fox news was
just brought on to the view so she was
from a sort of center-right news outlet
was brought onto this left-wing news
outlet and she was just there to plug
her book but she was asked about kovid
they wouldn't let her go into the studio
because she refused to take the
fouchyache they made a big deal about
this and then they railroaded her
because she was stating perfectly true
things about the virus
let's address the elephant in the room
because you were supposed to join you
were supposed to join us in the studios
weeks ago but you couldn't because abc
has a very strict policy uh you can't
get into this building unless you're
fully vaccinated everybody in this room
knows that and is vaccinated but you
made a conscious decision not to get the
vaccine i have a medical exemption to
the vaccine that's been written by my
infectious disease vaccinated specialist
in new york city that's been co-signed
by three other doctors i'm not a
candidate for this vaccine i also have
sky-high
multi-tiered multi-faceted natural
immunity very very high that has also
been proven it has been shown and it is
substantiated by letters from these
doctors so for me personally this
vaccine poses a greater risk than a
benefit but the vaccine does not prevent
you from getting coveted and does not
prevent you from transmitting oh my
goodness
yeah he's not so come on no you've been
at fox tv
i just don't understand why you would
choose to prioritize your personal
freedom over health and safety of others
and i just i just i just really don't
think that we should allow this kind of
misinformation um again
so jenna
jedediah's obviously right and the
cackling hands over the viewer are
not just rude and not just
unprofessional
i suppose their professional job
actually is to shut up conservatives so
there you go i guess they're being very
professional but but they're also wrong
here
they're also just what jedi said is
absolutely true the cdc admits that
about transmission of the virus and
contracting the virus even after the
vaccine the cdc admits that
so
what what they're saying what she's
saying is absolutely right then what
cackling hen number two i don't know her
name on the view said over there is i
don't know why you're
why you're prioritizing your personal
freedom over my safety jedidiah is not
what she said was she's prioritizing her
safety over perhaps your safety although
the point she's making also is that the
vaccinated people can still transmit the
virus as the cdc acknowledged at the end
of july which was their argument for why
vaccinated people still need to wear the
masks and socially distance and all that
other nonsense
so it's not it's not even a battle
between my freedom and
our safety it's it's a contest between
my safety and
oh and that's it and no one else is
safety because the
the threat to other people's safety is
not really going to change
and if the vaccine is so effective at
preventing you the recipient from from
hospitalization and death then you don't
need to worry about what someone else is
doing necessarily
but then they cut off her mic
they cut off her mic they say you've
been at fox news too long or you've been
you're too conservative or something
the woman is
reciting lines from the cdc from the
scientists from the public health
experts
but
they contradict the left's political
narrative and so they're going to cut it
off and i think the crucial thing about
this clip is when they cut her mic off
when she brings those facts when she
brings that science
they cut it off and they can cut it off
and yes you know you talk about fox news
it's kind of a center-right news outlet
there's some
conservative outlets out there on
alternative media obviously we're a very
large platform here at the daily wire
but the left
for the left it's not just a handful
like we have on the right it's abc nbc
cbs new york times this that the other
thing it's the whole it go it's the
whole blob
and so
they can cut you off and for most people
you're just going to hear the cackling
hands and you're not going to hear the
science this is why really getting back
to the rittenhouse case this is why the
central question that's affecting the
verdict it's affecting all all of this
trial
is not so much the evidence but
the media as the judge
lambasted uh the media for
just two days ago
some of the things that have been said
too i guess i'll comment on that too
these are
five very reputable competent attorneys
that i've practiced with for years
and i think it's shameful
some of the
things that are being done to these
people
and uh
i i when i talked about
um
problems with the media when this trial
started
that's
they're there in part not not fully but
in part because of grossly irresponsible
handling of
what comes out of this trial i will tell
you this
i'm going to think long and hard about
live television a trial again next time
i don't know i i've always been a firm
believer in it because i think the
people should be able to see what's
going on but when i see
what's being done is really quite
frightening frightening that's the right
word for it that is the right word and
so this verdict is not just about what
kyle rittenhouse did this verdict is not
just about our right to self-defense
this verdict will also
express how much
control the media have
over
shaping our entire society are we going
to be run
by a court of law or the court of public
opinion
shaped by the dishonest media i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode the
kyle ridden house defense team files for
a mistrial osha suspends its employer
vaccine mandate and a defendant takes
the stand in the ahmad arbory case
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire